there is new information about a
whistleblowers claim that is bringing a
top intelligence official to Capitol
Hill for closed-door testimony later
today we should Jiang is at the White
House with more on this story we Joe
how did this start well Gail we are
still waiting to find out a lot of the
details about this which remain a
mystery but here's what we know this
morning the Inspector General for the
intelligence community who is testifying
on Capitol Hill today concluded that a
complaint filed back in August was
credible enough to be considered quote
an urgent concern The Washington Post is
reporting that an interaction between
President Trump and a foreign leader is
at the center of a whistleblower report
which included a promise that was so
troubling it prompted a US intelligence
official to come forward House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff has issued a subpoena to obtain
the whistleblowers complaint but the
Acting Director of National Intelligence
Joseph McGuire is refusing to hand over
that report for now McGuire says he
determined the allegations did not merit
urgent concern and since they relate to
a person outside of the Intel community
he does not need to pass them along to
Capitol Hill shift pointed out that this
is the first time a Director of National
Intelligence has overruled a
determination from the Inspector General
and he raised concerns that this refusal
may indicate a cover-up to protect
President Trump on Sunday Schiff said on
Face the Nation that it is fair to
assume that this report involves the
president people around him
or both Anthony Regis things still so
much we don't know there